- [Instructor] So we're
given this expression
is the Taylor series about zero
for which of the following functions
and they give us some choices here.
So let's just think a
little bit about this series
that they gave us.
So if we were to expand it out,
let's see, when n is equal to zero,
it'd be negative one to the zero power
which is one times x to
the zero which is one
over zero factorial which is one
so it'll be one plus
and then when n is one,
well then this is going to be negative
so it's going to be minus
and then x to the first
over one factorial over,
well, I could just write
that as x over here
and then when n is two,
the negative one squared,
that's gonna be positive
x squared over two
and there's going to
be minus x to the third
over three factorial
and then it's going to be
plus and I can keep going.
You've seen this before.
x to the fourth over four factorial
and it's gonna keep going.
Minus, plus.
It's going to keep
alternating on and on and on.
Now, our general form for
a Taylor series about zero
which we could also call a
Maclaurin series would be,
our general form would be f of zero
plus f prime of zero times x
plus f prime prime of zero
times x squared over two
plus the the third derivative at zero
times x to the third over three factorial
plus the fourth derivative,
you get the idea,
evaluated at zero times x to
the fourth over four factorial
and we would just go on and on and on.
Now, to figure out which function,
in order what I wrote in
blue to be the Maclaurin
or to be the Taylor series about zero
or in order to be the Maclaurin series,
that means that,
that means that f of zero
needs to be equal to one.
It means that f prime of zero,
actually let me write this down.
It means that f of zero
needs to be equal to one.
f of zero is equal to one.
It means that f prime of zero
needs to be the coefficient on the x here
which is negative one
and we could keep going.
It means that, it means that
the second derivative at zero,
well, that's going to be the coefficient
on this x squared over two
so that's gotta be equal to one
and you see the general idea
that the third derivative at
zero is equal to negative one.
It's the coefficient on the x to the third
over three factorial which is
negative one right over here.
And so just using this information
can we figure out which of these it is.
So you could do a little bit
of deductive reasoning here.
Let's evaluate all of
these functions at zero
and see which of these are one.
So sine of zero.
Well, that's zero.
Just by looking at this first constraint,
sine of zero isn't one.
We can rule that out.
Cosine of zero is one so
that's still in the running.
e to the zero is one.
e to the zero is one
and then the natural log of one plus zero,
that's the natural log
of one which is a zero
so that's out of the running.
So just from that first constraint
knowing that f of zero is equal to one,
we're able to rule out two of the choices
then knowing that the first derivative
evaluated at zero is
going to be negative one
but what's the first
derivative of cosine of x?
Well, it's the negative sine of x.
If we evaluate that at zero,
we're not gonna get negative one.
We're gonna get zero so
we can rule this out.
Now, the first derivative
of e to the x is e to the x.
If we evaluate that at
zero, we're gonna get one,
not negative one so we can rule that out.
And so not even looking at anything else,
we have a pretty good sense
that D is probably our answer
but we could check.
The first derivative
here, f prime of x here
is going to be negative
e to the negative x.
So f prime of zero is going to be,
is going to be negative e
to the zero or negative one
so it meets that one
and if you were curious,
you could keep going
and see that it meets
all the other constraints
but choice D is the only one
that meets even the first two constraints
for the function at zero and
the first derivative at zero.